Guten Abend, mein Name ist Ali Alici. Ich bin auch dieser Stationsdienstabendarzt. Ich würde gerne jetzt mit dem, das auch noch eine Gespräche führen.
Sind wir damit einverstanden?
Ja, klar. Hauptsache, wie hilft jemand? Ja.
Ja.
Wie heißen Sie sich?
Ich heiße Kurt Bergmann.
Kurt? Bergmann.
Bergmann, genau.
Also am Ende zwei Ende?
Genau.
Wie alt sind Sie denn, Herr?
Ich bin 54 Jahre her, Dr. Alici.
Danke. Warum wurden Sie ganz genau geboren?
Am fünften, dritten, 68.
Okay. Wie viel wiegt ihr so seit?
Ah, so 80 Kilo.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Mein Pass steht 175. Denke das stimmt noch.
Danke.
Für die Informationen, Herr Bergmann, was kann ich denn so tun? Was haben Sie, was wir beschwörter haben, wie Sie sagen?
Ja, ich habe solche Schmerzen in meiner rechten Hand.
Muss ich dazusagen, ich bin vorhin mit dem Motorrad nach Hause gefahren.
Und dann war da so rutschiges Laub auf der Straße, bin ich umgefallen mit dem Motorrad.
Und ja, ich bin nicht richtig doll aufgefallen.
Aber ich habe mir offensichtlich die, irgendwie die Hand verletzt.
Die hat erst gar nicht so weh getan, aber jetzt tut sie mit einem ganz, ganz stark weh.
Und ich hatte ein Helm auf, also am Kopf habe ich mir nichts getan.
Aber ja, die Hand tut wirklich sehr heftig weh.
Okay.
Und ich kann die auch gar nicht so richtig bewegen.
Ihre Hand oder ganz Körper, meinen Sie?
Nein, die Hand, also der ganze Unterarm, das tut mir alles weh.
Und ich kann das im Gelenk gar nicht mehr bewegen.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Herr Bergmann, haben Sie zu seit auch einen Bauchschmerzen, Muskopschmerzen.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie tragen einen Helm, deswegen haben Sie keine Kopfschmerzen.
Am Kopf habe ich, ja, ich, die Brust tut mir ein bisschen weh.
Und zwar insbesondere beim Einatmen.
Das ist ein bisschen unangenehm.
Ach ja.
Welche Seite?
Rechte oder links?
Ich bin auf die rechte Seite gefallen und die rechte Hand tut mir weh.
Und ja, ich glaube auch so auf der rechten Seite, die Brust, das tut mir ein bisschen mehr weh.
Wenn Sie so tief einatmen, schmerzen wir.
Ja, dann tut das sehr weh, ja.
Deswegen atme ich jetzt gerade gar nicht so tief, ja.
Haben Sie auch Bauchschmerzen?
Bauchschmerzen habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Nein.
Okay.
Wann war denn das Unfall ganz genau?
Ja, das ist vielleicht so drei Stunden her.
Am Anfang war das gar nicht so doll.
Aber als es jetzt mit der Hand gar nicht besser wurde, ich war zum Glück schon fast zu Hause.
Und dann, da ist das passiert.
Und meine Frau hat mich jetzt gebracht.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie auch Weinschmerzen, Brustschmerzen oder...
Ja, ich glaube, ich habe da so ein paar blaue Flecken.
Also, das, aber das ist nicht so, nicht so schlimm, die Schmerzen.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Jetzt kommen wir wieder Ihre Hand, ja.
Also, haben Sie geschwollene Händgelenk oder Händgelenk?
Ja, ich habe das Gefühl, dass das ein bisschen geschwollt ist und dass ich das gar nicht mehr bewegen kann.
Und hat sich die Farbe verändert, so laulich, rotisch oder?
Ja, ich glaube ein bisschen bläulich sieht das aus, ja.
Okay.
Herr Bergmann, während dieser Umfang, haben Sie Ihre Bössein verloren?
Nein, ganz sicher nicht.
Nein, nein.
Ich habe gemerkt, wie mir das Hinterrad weggerutscht ist und zack mit einmal lag ich.
Also, das war, ich war die ganze Zeit dabei.
Okay.
War Ihnen schwindel oder haben Sie so statt Schwindel?
Sind Sie schwindelig?
Schwindelig ist mir nicht, nein.
Also, haben Sie Fieber, Stilfrost oder?
Nein, sowas habe ich alles nicht.
Nein, nein, ich fühle mich eigentlich nicht wirklich krank.
Das ist halt nur diese wirklich starken Handschmerzen.
Okay.
Übelkeit auch nicht.
Bitte?
Übelkeit. Leider so unterübel.
Übelkeit ist mir auch nicht.
Okay.
Gut.
Herr Bergmann.
Ich möchte etwas Ihres Krankgeschichte etwas wissen.
Leiden Sie unter, also wichtige Vorerkrankungen.
Ich meine, wie Blutdruck.
Ja, also ich habe ein bisschen niedrigen Blutdruck.
Das ist schon seit zehn Jahren bekannt.
Das ist eigentlich ungewöhnlich.
Alle Leute haben einen hohen Blutdruck.
Ich habe niedrigen Blutdruck.
Und dann habe ich vor fünf Jahren einen Bandscheibenvorfall gehabt
in der Halsbibelsäule.
Und da bin ich noch so ein bisschen eingeschränkt.
Also da muss ich halt ein bisschen aufpassen.
Und dann habe ich ein bisschen Neurodermitis an den Armen.
Das habe ich aber schon als Kind gehabt.
Nehmen Sie dagegen irgendwelche Medikamente ein.
Zum Beispiel.
Ja, also für die Haut, für die Haut nehme ich Cortisonseil,
wenn das unangenehm wird.
Und dann habe ich Tropfen, die den Blutdruck nach oben bringen soll.
Ich kann dir aber jetzt nicht sagen, wie die heißen.
Und wenn ich mal Schmerzen habe, also gerade auch in dem Halsbereich,
dann nehme ich Ibuprofen.
Und dann komme ich eigentlich ganz gut zurecht.
Ibuprofen, wie ist die Dosierung?
Oh, ich glaube, das sind 600 oder 600 Leute.
Ich weiß gar nicht genau.
Okay.
Herr Bergmann.
Leiden Sie unter.
Nein.
Haben Sie alle gegen bestimmte etwas?
Ja, zum Beispiel.
Hausstau oder Polen, Medikamente.
Was ich nicht vertragen kann, ist Kontrastmittel.
Das hat man mal festgestellt.
Wie hauptsächlich wissen.
Ja, ich habe da, ich habe da so so ein bisschen.
So so rote, rote Gesicht bekommen.
Und ich glaube, ich hatte auch ein bisschen Probleme mit der Atmung.
Okay.
Und in Funke sind Sie vorständig geimpft?
Ich meine.
Ich bin mir also Corona auf alle Fälle klar.
Ich bin mir jetzt aber doch klar.
Doch ich habe auch kürzlich, so vor nicht allzu langer Zeit,
eine.
Eine Tetanus Impon gehabt.
Ja, das ist aber gut.
Herr Bergmann, waren Sie in der letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, im Ausland war ich nicht.
Okay.
Herr Bergmann, lebt ihr Eltern noch?
Meine Mutter, die lebt noch.
Mein Vater ist relativ früh gestorben.
Aber meine Mutter, die lebt noch.
Leiden Sie unter irgendwelche Krankheiten?
Ja, also mein Vater hat den Herzinfarkt,
so müssen sie daran gestorben.
Und meine Mutter, die hat so im schläfen Bereich
einen weißen Hautkrebs.
Das ist operiert worden.
Aber sonst geht es da eigentlich ganz gut.
Weißen Hautkrebs, wo war denn das?
Im Schläfenbereich bei meiner Mutter.
Okay.
Danke. Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe eine Schwester.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ist sie gesund?
Nicht wirklich.
Wie ist Magersüchtig, meine Schwester?
Entschuldigung, ich habe etwas nicht ganz genau verstanden.
Was haben Sie gesagt?
Meine Schwester ist Magersüchtig.
Okay.
Herr Bergmann, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Was machen Sie, warum nicht?
Ich arbeite als Tierpfleger im Zoo.
Okay, das ist mal gut.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben drei Kinder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, ja.
Noch ein paar Fragen.
Herr Bergmann, rauchen Sie?
Nicht mehr so wie früher, aber ein paar Zigaretten rauchen es.
Ich habe früher, 20 Jahre lang,
ich habe jeden Tag ein Päckchen geraucht.
Aber seit fünf Jahren,
seit vier Jahren rauche ich nur noch fünf Zigaretten am Tag.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Alkohol, also ich trinke abends wohl mal eine Flasche Bier.
Wenn es mal etwas zu feiern gibt, trinkt man auch mal ein Schluck mehr.
Aber so regelmäßig ein Bier am Abend kann man gar.
Nur Bier, ja?
Ja.
Nehmen Sie bitte diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit den Drogen?
Mit Drogen habe ich keinen Kontakt.
Herr Bergmann, ich möchte wissen,
haben Sie seit einer Kribbelgefühl,
Taubheit in der Rechtenarme oder Hände?
Kribbel im rechten Arm habe ich nicht.
Nein, es sind nur häfige Schmerzen,
aber so ein Taubheitsgefühl oder so,
das habe ich nicht.
Könnten Sie mir die Schmerzen beschreiben?
Nein, ich habe keine Schmerzen.
Ist eine Stischende brennende, siehende?
Ja.
Also stechend trifft es wahrscheinlich.
Stechend und bohrend.
Und bohrend irgendwie.
Also, ja, ich kann das schwer beschreiben.
Aber es tut jedenfalls sehr, sehr weh.
Okay.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskale?
Ja, wie wie?
So kann man bezeichnen, ja.
Also von 0 bis 10, also 0 ernst.
Ja, da sind sie.
Keine Schmerzen, 10, unerträgliche Schmerzen.
Ja, da sind sie schon bei 7 bis 8, das sind schon wirklich
sehr starke Schmerzen.
Sehr höchstig Schmerzen.
Wir haben ja nicht dagegen etwas gegeben.
Ja.
Okay.
Herr Badmann.
Das war alles.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder Fragen haben?
Ja, die Frage ist natürlich, wie lange dauert es hier?
Kann ich wieder nach Hause?
Was meinen Sie?
Wann kann ich wieder arbeiten gehen?
Das ist natürlich das, was mir so oft in Nägel brennt.
Ja, es ist zu früh etwas zu sagen.
Aber wir als,
als haben immer drei Schritte, um richtige Diagnosen
stellen zu können.
So als nehmen wir eine Anameski-Spreche,
wir machen wir, führen wir,
dann körperliche Untersuchung, danach Apparativdiagnose.
Bisher haben wir nur die anamesstische
Gespräche behandelt.
Ich würde jetzt sie körperlich untersuchen.
Ja, dann, dann möchte ich ein paar Röntgen
auch nehmen.
Ja, als diagnostischen Massnahmen würde ich
den bildgebenden Verfahren Röntgen
veranlassen.
Dann kann ich noch richtige etwas sagen,
aber wahrscheinlich, sie haben eine
Handgelenkbruchung.
Was kann man denn damit machen?
Ich bin nicht, ich bin nicht, ja, das, wie gesagt,
aber das ist nur eine Verdach, ja.
Braucht noch weitere Untersuchungen,
wie gesagt, um eine Röntgen auch nehmen.
Danach richtig etwas sagen.
Okay, gut, dann schicken Sie mich jetzt direkt zum,
ah nee, erst muss ich nämlich körperlich untersuchen.
Ich möchte so erst körperlich untersuchen,
danach werde ich...
Okay, gut, alles klar.
Haben Kollegen an dir Fragen?
Haben Sie Taubkreisstücke in Ihrem Handgelenk?
Hab ich gerade schon verneint,
habe ich nicht, nein.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlasten
und Sturrenk?
Ah, warte mal, der hat irgendwas.
Ja, der neigt zu Durchfall der Mann, ja.
Das habe ich nicht gefragt, nicht nötig,
deswegen, also normalerweise,
vielleicht, dass es nötig ist,
weil es sich nicht so eine Umfahl,
oder nicht, haben Sie oft von der Runde?
Aha, also ich glaube, er hat sich so ein bisschen abgeschürft
und hat sich das aber nicht so ganz genau angeguckt, ja.
Aber er hat ja gesagt, er hat blaue Flecken
und ich glaube, so ein bisschen abgeschürft ist das wohl auch,
aber keine großen Fleischrunden.
Sie haben gesagt,
wie sieht aus die Durchfall?
Ach so, ja, der ist hier hin und wieder,
ist der mal ein bisschen dünnflüssig
oder weich der Sturren.
Aber dann sieht man halt das Essen,
was man vorher gegessen hat.
Okay, seit wann haben Sie?
Auch schon lange, schon eigentlich, ja,
seit vielen Jahren, immer mal wieder.
Hallo, haben Sie eine Verstellung bei Ihrem Arm bemerkt?
Hab ich nicht bemerkt, nein.
Alles klar.
Ich würde gerne sagen,
diese Trauma,
eine Pneumotrax einführt,
deswegen müssen wir
erst einmal Pneumotrax fragen.
Das habe ich vergessen, ja.
Und eine Notfallstation
und wir müssen zuerst Italie seichen.
Italienparameter.
Überprüfen.
Das habe ich vergessen.
Ich habe mich nicht bemerkt,
aber ich habe mich nicht bemerkt,
dass ich eine Brustkropschmerz habe.
Wenn Sie tief hat,
das entspricht eine Rettanfragtur.
Deswegen muss ich vergessen,
haben Sie Atemnot oder Rheissüsten?
Ja, aber wenn man den Patienten gegenüber sitzt,
merkt man,
ich habe ja nicht jappsend vor der Kamera gehangen.
Sie haben eine Beschwerde nicht erzählt,
aber möglicherweise,
das könnte passieren.
Vielleicht seitlich eine Pneumotrax hermachen.
Hat recht dafür.
Ich bin natürlich ein Allgemeinschuhguck,
deswegen habe ich nicht viele Erfahrungen dafür.
Meister sitzen wie Sie.
Natürlich, klar.
Es gibt keine Emotionen.
Das ist die Schwierigkeit.
Dass wir eine künstliche Situation haben.
Genau genommen.
Klar hätten wir jetzt sagen können,
wir haben eine kleine Situation,
die wir uns anschließen.
Wir fragen weiter.
Das kann man nicht richtig in der Situation simulieren.
Aber der Hinweis ist natürlich gut,
dass man sagt,
müsste ich jetzt einig machen.
Als du es hier anfangen,
fragst du es.
Das ist ein bisschen schwierig.
Der ist für alle der schwierigste Teil.
Das wissen wir ja.
Die Fragen laufen immer gut.
Der Bericht ist dann ein bisschen schwieriger.
Machen Sie ganz in Ruhe.
Vielleicht.
Er knirscht ein bisschen mit den Zähnen.
Ja, okay.
Guten Tag.
Frau Oberarzt.
Ich habe einen neuen Patientin aufgenommen.
Ich würde Ihnen diese Patientin vorstellen.
Ich möchte die Patientin vorstellen.
Hätten Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, natürlich.
Herr Kurz.
Baldmann ist da.
Ein 54-jähriger Patient.
Der sich heute Morgen bei uns aufgrund
vor 3 Stunden.
3 Stunden.
Bestehende.
Bruchende.
Brechseitige.
Handgelenk Schmerzen.
Vorgestellt hat.
Der Patientin.
Ich habe vor 3 Stunden.
Eine Motorradunfall durchgeführt.
Eine Motorradunfall gemacht.
Und die Patientin.
Ich habe vor 3 Stunden.
Eine Motorradunfall durchgeführt.
Und Brechseitige gestürzt.
Seitdem.
Hat er.
Ich habe er.
Rechthand Schmerzen.
Der Patientin berichtet.
Dass die Schmerzen.
Plöstlich auch getreten.
Natürlich.
Plöstlich auch.
Mit dem Unfall.
Ja.
Und sich in Verlaufe der Zeit verschlechtert hätten.
Das ist richtig.
Teilte er mit.
Auf einer Schmerzskala.
Bei 7.
8.
Ein so Ordnern sein.
Das ist ein Schmerzskala.
Und.
Darüber hinaus.
Teilte er mit.
Dass er in.
Rechseitige.
Muss Schmerzen.
Wenn er tief atmen.
Haben.
Ein so Ordner.
Darüber hinaus.
Teilte er mit.
Was er.
tief atmen.
habe.
habe er.
Torcalgie.
Und.
Wir.
Passieren.
Tragen.
Trage.
Deswegen.
Also hat er bei dem Unfall.
Ja.
Noch etwas.
Wir Patienten.
Wir.
Rechseitige.
Handgelenke geschwollene und.
Beläublich.
Aber.
Geschwollene und.
Aber auch beläublich.
Die vegetative.
Anamnese.
Ist.
Unauffällig bis auch.
Durchwahl.
Seit.
Ja.
80.
Seit.
Ja.
Überdurchwahl.
An Vorerkrankungen leidere.
An.
Hypotonie.
Also ich habe vergessen seit wann.
gegessen seit wann, aber wer passiert ist hier, während und versuchen, wenn ich ihn fragen.
dagegen nehme er eine Tropfen, dass er die Namen nicht kennen.
und Norbert mittels, dagegen nehme er Korps und Salbe und Lumba Gristhirne, bei Baddach
und über Profen 600 Millikran.
Herr Bergmann, hat Kontrastalergie auf Kontrastmittel reagiert.
sich mit Hautausschlag und Atemnode an Dispeneu. Bergmann sei vollständig geämpft, auch Corona-Würst.
Also, als Familien, als sein Vater hat verstorben, auch von Myokartinfarkten.
Mutter leide an weiße Hautkrebs, Carcinum, Masillum, im Kopfbereich.
Sie hat eine Schwester, sie leide an Gastritis.
Er ist beruflich, macht Tier, arbeitet in einem so und als Tierpfleger.
Er hat 3 gesunde Kinder, er ist sein Raucher, seit 20 Jahren.
Er hat ein Packunggerau, aber die letzte 5 Jahre rauchte er nur 4 Stigaretten.
Das entspricht 21 Peggjah.
Er trinkt regelmäßig täglich ein Bier und sie konsumiert kein Droger.
Die anonystischen Angaben deuten eine Handgelenkfraktur hin.
Als differenzialen Diagnose kommen weiche Gewebe, Verlärsungen, Kontusion.
Das kann man noch sagen.
Was machen Sie jetzt diagnostisch mit dem Patient?
Woher achten Sie besonders?
Manchmal hört man das Wort.
Was sind noch sichere Frakturzeichen?
Wenn über einen Breitrippenfraktur, den unten, die Handgelenk, meinst du?
Die Fehlstellung ist typisch.
Das können wir hören, ob es knirscht.
Was machen Sie noch von der reinen Inspektion?
Ich möchte erst die Inspektion sehen.
Die Handgelenk oder die Ahnungnoren, die sich an der Inspektion sind, können wir sehen, ob sich andere tun.
Die Schmerzen beurteilen, wo am stärksten sind.
Wir können im Torax-Bereich auch per Christian untersuchen machen.
Was ist die Maßnahme beim Hemmhautorox?
Der Kram ist gerade in der Stichwort eingeblendet.
Wenn es nötig ist, dann machen wir es durch.
Das können wir mit der Ultraschall beurteilen.
Wenn über 5% eine Knormor Torax steht, dann müssen wir eine Torax durchführen.
Was machen Sie mit dem Patient?
Wenn wir einen Verdach auf Blutung haben, dann können wir eine Blutbild für die Hemoglobinkonzentration bestimmen.
Wenn wir weiter denken, dass wir unter Umständen transfundieren müssen, dann müssen wir die Blutgruppen bestimmen.
Was würde denn dann weiterlaufen mit der Diagnostik und Bildgebung?
Als Erstmaßnahme würde ich die Patienten stationell aufnehmen.
Dann untersuchen wir die Teilparameter.
Danach würde ich Ultraschall und Sonografie durchführen.
Wie geben es fast eine Torax-City für Anlass?
Die Hand, die Hand, eine Rotgernaufnahme für Anlass, das reicht.
Wir geben fast eine Operation für den Handgelenk.
Ein Rückscheller ein Gips?
Ja, möglicherweise auch erst nach Abschwellen.
Wenn der Hand schon dick aufgeschwollen ist, dann kann man unter Umständen gar nichts machen.
Was machen Sie mit den Patienten mit dem Medikamentös?
Das ist sehr unterschiedlich.
Wenn er eine Pneumotorax hat, dann ist das ganz unterschiedlich.
Aber wenn nur eine Handgelenkfraktur ist, dann ist das anders.
Wir geben eine Schmerzmittel.
Wenn der offene Wunder ist, dann müssen wir eine Antibiotik verschreiben.
Natürlich müssen wir nachweis haben, dass er seit 5 Jahren eine Tetanusinfunk hat.
Das muss man noch mal checken.
Das ist bei mir auch alles, was ich auf dem Zettel habe.
Ich bin gespannt, was bei Ihren Untersuchungen rauskommt.
Es wäre natürlich interessant, was hinsichtlich des Torax rauskommt.
Dann ist natürlich auch die Frage, wie kompliziert dieses Handgelenk in Mitleidenschaft gezogen ist.
Haben Sie einen Fachbegriff für die Torax-Trinage?
Das ist eine Schlauch-Trinage.
Dann bleibt das Ding unter Sog, bis die Lunge sich sicher entfaltet hat.
So lange kriegen die so eine Saugflasche an den Schlauch.
Das war es von mir aus.
Halten Sie mich bitte auf dem Laufen, wenn etwas mit Ihrem Patienten ist.
Das ist relativ selten.
Ich weiß aber, dass es nach Bundesland gibt es Traumata.
Sie sind schon bekannt.
Ich meine, der Fall kommt aus München, wenn ich mich nicht ganz talsche.
Sie haben gesagt, er ist geimpft, auch Corona.
Ich habe gesagt, vorständig geimpft, auch gegen habe ich vergessen.
Er hat einen Unfall gehabt und ist auf die rechte Seite gestürzt.
Das finde ich immer relativ schwierig.
Ich habe bei allen Kollegen aufgefallen, wo man so Unfallhergang beschreibt.
Das ist immer schwierig.
Er nimmt gegen den niedrigen Blutdruck Tropfen, deren Namen er nicht kennt.
Er nimmt einen Medikament, dessen Namen er nicht kennt.
Ich habe mir nichts weiter aufgeschrieben.
Die Schwester hat gesagt, er ist magersüchtig.
Ich meine, dass in diesem speziellen Fall die Prüfer, die nehmen jeden Seitenhinweis auf, um noch mal etwas zu fragen.
Ich meine, in diesem Fall hätten die auch tatsächlich nach der Anarixier Neurosa gefragt.
Man muss genau hinhören.
Ich habe das gehört, magersüchtig.
Magersüchtig ist das ein Gastritis.
Wenn wir eine Strasse haben, dann sollen wir wieder fragen, was sie damit sagen.
Vielleicht die Prüfer sagen, wissen sie das nicht.
Ich weiß es schon, aber könnten Sie etwas beschreiben, was Sie da meinen?
Es ist tatsächlich eine Sache, die mit der Geschichte nichts zu tun hat.
Es ist irreleerant.
Ich weiß nur, dass die Prüfer solche kleinen Hinweise manchmal aufnehmen.
Manchmal fragen die nach den Krankheiten der Familienanamese ganz dezidiert
und wollen zu jedem Ding irgendwas wissen.
Dann bin ich immer völlig fachungslos nach dem Motto, was hat es mit dem Fall zu tun.
Aber denen geht es um die Sprache.
Die wollen wissen, haben sie verstanden, was der über seinen Vater, über seine Mutter und über seine Schwester gesagt hat.
Und insofern ist das tatsächlich etwas, womit sie rechnen müssen.
Auch wenn es in dem Zusammenhang relativ wurscht ist, ob die Schwester jetzt magersüchtig ist oder eine Gastritis hat,
das ist für dessen Unfallschmerzen mit der Hand und mit dem Großkopf völlig unwichtig.
Nur für die Prüfer, die wollen wissen, haben sie verstanden, was der Patient ihnen erzählt hat.
Und insofern ist es eben schon wichtig, wenn sie sich nicht sicher sind, tatsächlich nochmal nachhagen.
Oder wäre natürlich auch noch eine Strategie dann verschweigen.
Wenn sie sich nicht sicher sind, nicht weiter erwähnen.
Und dann kann das natürlich passieren, dass die Prüfer sagen, hey, was hat der denn zur Schwester gesagt?
Kann Ihnen passieren.
Ja, grüßt das.
Gut.
Ja, danke.